Đi cơ, điện phải ai phương, mà chipped mình sấu,
hôm ca cái điện, là sắp xa của quân,
mộ cai năm, hay phùm sẽ sắp đi.
Thấy làm công ty về công nghệ.
Thì cai ăn đi của mình phải mặng, cai không ty kẻ.
Và cái gì đó là được, được ca,
thì có mình mà là công ty kẻ.
Là nó nằm ở số đường phải mình phải chức được.
Thế chẳng được, thì ta cắt ăn của mình đầu tiên,
thì nó mất, mình xấu ấy năm,
cái màu màu có cái em, hẹn đầu tiên gây.
Thì lúc mà cắt lại thì nó đã 8 hơi mời.
Là, từ mình cũng có cái gì ra cái màu,
gắt của cái gì em,
thì phải là cái gì vậy?
Cái gì màu cũng là,
đã làm công nghệ,
là mình phải sing,
tục phát mình đi trước đó thậu.
Chiu phải là mình chỉ phát mình,
ra một cái này là trong cái gì là mình sống.
Là gì cái đó nó có thể giúp mình sống bạn,
năm năm, năm, năm, giữa đó,
cho tất cả cái người ta khách,
mình chỉ là hơi mình,
chương phải chỉ phát mình mộ cái gì là nó một lần.
Là là dạy, với sống, bớt đại không phải.
Ngày nào, và chúng ta dừng phát mình,
bớt thậu phát mình trước,
thì đó là ngày đầu tiên cũng để các đầu sinh nhau.
Mặc dầu, có thể giang tố hình,
là của mình đã đại tố,
với những sẽ không nghĩa.
Thả đại yêu,
là thành viên vào đó,
và tảy là của một công tiên công nghệ,
nó có thể ngay nào,
và mà mình bắt đầu dừng phát mình,
mà nó mặc đặt khách mình mình kế mà lưới thậu,
là ngày đó mình đã đại gỗ vận của tiên là trước.
Đi quên,
những đúc xem thế,
thì sẽ tỏng bộ bố khác,
tập mời nhất.